villa schweppes plage du majestic ou
encore baoli la nuit cannoise bat son
plein pendant le festival 2 yvelinois
xhavit polycarpe et vincent brunet ont
animé l'une de ses soirées à l'atelier
des merveilles éphémère
le chanteur m s'est également joint à la
partie jeunes et xavier et vincent ont
fréquenté le même lycée à la celle saint
cloud après leur carrière respective ils
se sont retrouvés et ont créé macadam
crocodile xavier et vincent vous
représentez donc le groupe macadam
crocodile vous produisez ce samedi 12
mai sur la terrasse du fei six hôtels
dans le cadre de la soirée des ateliers
des merveilles éphémère parlez-nous déjà
de l'univers de macadam crocodile qui
allie style cet univers c'est un univers
qui est retranscrit par un internaute de
faciès déjà énoncé c'est tout part d'un
d'une une sorte de revenir 2
deux collectifs qu'on a depuis longtemps
on a beaucoup de jamie ensemble depuis
des années et des années et des années a
eu plein de projets ensemble on vient là
on a fait de même lycée etc
et voilà l univers c'était c'est avant
tout le val a le plaisir le plaisir de
jouer et de se regarder dans les yeux
dessus un peu voilà musicalement ça
donne quoi habituellement musicalement
puisqu'elle mme en c1
oui sa part donc d'une envie de jouer en
boucle de d'essayer de faire monter ce
qu'on peut dire une certaine trans dans
la musique apporte une certaine tranche
avec la répétition mais on va dire que
les opus no no no fin nos influences et
il ya de la funk de l'afro funk et
mélangé avec du disco du new disco
voilà il le truc plus moderne voilà un
peu trippant quand on peut dire aussi
qu'ils permettent de voir la 2d longue
montée des dons vous envoler et c'est
uniquement aussi des performances en
live c'est ça jusqu alors c'est qu'on a
fait ou n'a rien ne soit enregistrée en
fait on n'a rien enregistré c'est que du
live et on voit là on a fait beaucoup de
concerts donc on se demande peut être si
on n'a pas enregistré et le fait d'être
présent ici à cannes pendant le festival
est ce que c'est un choix de votre part
peut-être vous passionnés de cinéma où
ça s'est fait tout à fait par hasard
cette programmation est le fait de joie
ici ce soir c'est une très grosse
opportunité c'est une très grosse
opportunité pour pour cannes de nous
avoir en ce samedi 12 mais c'est vrai
enfin en fait le festival s'est
construit autour de nous ça veut dire
que cette année on voulait faire du
macadam crocodile avant tout on s'est
dit qu'est ce qu'on peut faire un
peut-être qu'on peut faire un festival
de cinéma et c'est effectivement on aime
bien le cinéma et des films commencent
et c'est là c'est loïc a donc qui
s'occupe de l'âme c'est qu'il est à dire
que c'est dans un endroit où on joue ce
soir qui nous a pas contactés il ya des
amis
oui nous ont proposé de venir pour le
festival de fil en aiguille avec toute
une bande de musiciens congolais qui on
est amis on habite de jouer en pensant
et de matthieu chedid qui a été là aussi
donc c'est super on a fait un super
jamie hier de deux heures et qu'est-ce
que vous avez concocté à ce soir pour
personnes qui vont assister à cette
performance de la sphère et j'espère de
l' envie de danser parce que notre but
c'est que voilà les gens dansent et se
faire plaisir et de faire plaisir vous
faire danser les gens on est vraiment
dans ce truc là de faire partie de la de
faire partie de la fête quoi jusqu'à
qu'un show
à proprement parler merci merci la vie
merci à toi catégorie
[Musique]
voilà
et puis dernier focus de la semaine sur
un film financé par la région
ile-de-france mari mange revient avec
joueurs premier long métrage de la
réalisatrice sélectionnés au sein de la
quinzaine des réalisateurs festival
parallèle à cannes joueurs se déroule
dans les milieux du jeu parisien est là
une jeune femme normale rencontre abel
un flambeur qui l'entraînent dans sa
passion et son addiction
50 50
on va manger un bout
quel écran mois
voilà c'est sur ces images que se
referme le rideau de cannes 60,18 merci
de nous avoir suivi toute cette semaine
khan 60 18,7 à revoir sur notre site
internet et notre application mobile tv
[Musique]